voici les premières images de l'impact
arrivés dans l'après-midi elles ont été
capturées par une sonde italienne qui
accompagnait dart le vaisseau principal
de l'opération celui qui a fait vibrer
la communauté scientifique la nuit
dernière avec ses images incroyables à
gauche la stéroïde didimos à droite
dimorphoses sont satellites 160 mètres
de diamètre sur les images filmées par
la caméra embarquée la cible se
rapproche progressivement jusqu'au plan
final attestant de l'impact
si la première étape est réussie la
deuxième consiste à savoir si l'Impact a
bien dévié ce caillou de 160 mètres de
diamètre
[Applaudissements]
sur cette image prise par des télescopes
géants on voit le souffle de l'impact
sur l'astéroïde d'immorphoses les
ingénieurs ayant travaillé sur le projet
ont de quoi se réjouir cette mission est
pour eux riches d'enseignement il est
encore trop tôt pour savoir si l'orbite
de dimorphose a été modifié réponse dans
quelques semaines en revanche pour
découvrir réellement les conséquences de
l'impact il faudra attendre quatre ans
avec l'arrivée des rats le satellite
européen en attendant les résultats une
chose est sûre pour les scientifiques
aucun astéroïde connu une menace notre
planète pour les 100 prochaines années
je voulais vous parler d'une nouvelle
émission qui est lancée sur Amazon ça
s'appelle ring nation c'est une sorte de
vidéo gag des temps mod parce que c'est
basé sur des vidéos
issues de caméras de surveillance alors
c'est principalement faut le dire des
vidéos d'animaux il y a l'ours qui
s'introduit dans votre voiture ou le
serpent qui se cache sous votre
paillasson quand vous rentrez vous en
êtes chez vous des chutes en tout genre
des demandes en mariage et puis bien sûr
des enfants mignons et souvent les
propriétaires de ces sonnettes postent
ces vidéos donc sur les réseaux sociaux
et ça fait un carton c'est à dire que
cette vidéo de du pauvre livreur qui
tombe livreur Amazon et bien elle a été
vu plus de 3 millions de fois sur Tik
Tok et donc l'émission de télévision
ring nation en temps surfer sur ce
mouvement en proposant des compilations
de ces séquences le tout présenté par
une humoriste américaine qui s'appelle
Vanda sight on touche le fond au niveau
du contenu et pourtant cette émission
elle est pas encore sortie qu'elle fait
polémique car amazon est soupçonnée de
vouloir redorer le blason de sa propre
marque de sonnette c'est les sonnettes
ring d'où le nom de la mission des
sonnettes avec caméra et haut-parleur
intégré qui vous promettent la sécurité
de votre maison mais pour ces
détracteurs c'est tout le contraire
c'est sonnette serait en vrai en fait de
véritables espions capables de
surveiller au fait et gestes des mines
d'or pour les hackers selon edmarke un
sénateur américain cette émission de
télé-réalité en fait c'est une publicité
pour un produit Amazon les sonnettes
ring le tout qui se cache derrière
soi-disant donc du divertissement or
c'est un mélange des genres qui est très
très dangereux parce que ça banalise la
vidéo surveillance en la faisant passer
pour un jeu et certains Américains
visiblement sont en train de prendre
goût à ce drôle de mélange des gens
entre vidéosurveillance et puis
divertissement c'est ainsi qu'aux
États-Unis une petite fille dans sa
chambre s'est retrouvée à discuter par
vidéo interposées avec un hacker qui
s'est fait passer pour le Père Noël
les vidéos ring sont censées nous faire
pleurer de rire de tout envie de pleurer
tout court
que ça se passe autrement mais c'est le
jeu c'est la compète et en fait
clairement on se rend compte qu'il y a
plus de la moitié des personnes qui sont
déjà parties et qu'on fait partie de
l'autre moitié parce qu'on est arrivé
dans ce genre on était 50 et aujourd'hui
on est plus que 24 c'est un truc de ouf
c'est oufissisme le 4
parfois heureux de surcroît pour huit
points
de l'équipe de France c'est pas des
hommes politiques c'est pas des hommes
et des femmes politiques c'est pas non
plus des fonctionnaires du Quai d'Orsay
et diplomatique ils sont là pour jouer
donc élevés entre guillemets leur niveau
de conscience en ayant des éléments
d'information sur le contexte dans
lequel ils vont évoluer ça me semble
souhaitable parce que on peut pas en
appeler au discernement à la maturité
dans d'autres situations et ne pas les
informer contribuer à leur ouverture sur
ces sujets-là
vous avez dépensé des sommes
complètement folles pour un marabout
mais ça a commencé tout doucement par
des petits investissements des petits
sacrifices comme on dit dans le dans le
jargon et jusqu'à ce que je m'en rende
compte je suis arrivé à un peu de temps
à 200.000 euros
ça paraît dingue d'avoir dépensé des
sommes aussi importantes c'est un moment
de bonheur et rire ça participe aussi et
c'est pour ça que j'ai dit on s'en fout
pas dans mes franchement les valeurs du
sport c'est aussi l'éthique là les fait
passer pour des pour des triples on part
vendre elle suggère qu'on veut c'est des
fouteuses on peut mettre
on vous a demandé de sacrifier votre
fils c'est ça
ouais déjà j'étais fatigué j'étais
fatigué parce que ça a duré environ deux
ans
que je tournais en rond ma situation ne
s'améliorerait pas et j'étais fatigué
financièrement aussi parce que je suis
rentré dans mes économies et à la fin
me demander subtilement de sacrifier mon
fils pour moi c'était trop
moi je suis HS avec les enfants la maman
[Musique]